hey guys welcome back to the game spot
stage here at e3 2016 this is brought to
you by airheads i'm your host mary i'm
still give me your next your host for
probably like another hour and i am
delighted to be joined but my co-host
and good buddy peter brown hello and we
also have psionics in the house we have
Josh Watson and Jeremy Dunham hello
thank you guys for being here having us
and I've said this before but thank you
again for making the I think it's
probably the second game in the history
of GameSpot that have made our managers
have required specified times that we're
allowed to play it in the office welcome
yeah was the first time I believe it was
the original I was it was counter-strike
uh yeah good choice yeah it had to be
counter-strike of course i would say
something else but it's totally casual a
that we can contribute to your counter
productivity that's right yeah there's
nothing else it would it would be that
um so I mean obviously we're here
because you guys really something we've
been freaking out about it's neo tokyo
the new this is a there's a few things
going on here not only is it a new map
well a new environment for you guys to
play in but there's a couple new cars
all sorts of stuff um this is all done
in the vibe of neo tokyo it looks rad
it's neon you guys even said there's a
few pieces we want to get into here but
there's even like new voice call outs
yes so neo tokyo we were really inspired
by a lot of our guys in the studio
really inspired by Blade Runner and
Japanese anime and that the whole 80s
vibe so we wanted a cat and capture the
idea that you were in 1980s Neo Tokyo so
we've done the voiceover for all the
things that happen in the game we've
changed it to actual Japanese so the
countdown and whenever you score and
good gratulations all sorts of stuff
what do they yell when you score I've
depends on multiple things so some of
them are like this nice shot but in
Japanese and all the time to say
congratulations and sometimes there's
just a sound reaction but it so really
depends it's a little bit a little bit
contextual in that regard but they're
quite a few phrases in there what's so
exciting now I'm along with that you
guys had you guys had as oh here we're
getting some
gameplay know this is actually live this
is happening right now we have people
playing this in our studio this is what
Neo Tokyo looks like we can already see
you guys have raised sides you've
changed up the map a little bit they're
kind of reminiscent of the previous maps
you guys released earlier when you guys
were working with the community what
have you guys changed to this map
visually as we're looking at this
actually looks familiar to a map I've
already seen yes it is originally in
rocket labs and when we launch rocket
labs we always said that we wanted to
use that as sort of a testing ground for
new environments in new arenas and if
people really liked it or took to them
we would then fully art them out and add
some cool aspects to it yeah this was
the double decker map from rocket labs
and I remember most the community saying
of all the maps there was like the donut
uh that's what I called it is ova
straight up donut this one was the one
that changed up the dynamic of the
gameplay the most it made it changed it
in such wonderful ways and it made
people use aerials and height and
communication with team skills it's all
about having that extra set of height
getting some real nice aerials out of
that I'm so good for for team scores so
sounds like you guys had positive
community feedback in this is this going
in the rotation this I think it
confirmed on Twitter so that's that's
one of the things that we wanted to make
sure is that this is not just for
exhibition play of salsa for raked play
it's going to be it's going to be part
of that's going to be ready to go on jun
20th is when you release release the
patch so it's just a few days from now
and it's it's one of our favorite maps
even before we are today that we just
liked the concept of it because it it
still felt familiar but it also added
the new strategy because of the the way
that it promotes aerials and driving on
the banks I know it was your favorite
map yeah absolutely ever it was my
favorite when we tested it it really
does kind of work with in tandem for
co-op play this is about working with
your teammates to have a ball set real
high and then smash down so it might be
happening right now they're the job
caveman AI isn't it yes score done one
thing we changed a little bit when we
when we released underpass we got a lot
of feedback about the back walls causing
a little bit
much height so we wanted to kind of
normalize them a little bit so we worked
really closely with the community
feedback and tried to do we round it out
some of the edges on the the levels here
and and flatten the back so it plays a
little bit more like the standard maps
and now you guys are also playing with
brand new cars you guys just announced
yes well tell me a little bit about them
and I have to ask because it looks like
there's neon in them are these
customizable so they are customizable
yeah that's it's just like any of our
other cars that we we introducing gold
you can add flags you can add rocket
boots you can do whatever you want this
one that Lucas using now is masamune and
it's one of the two neo tokyo theme cars
we have what's in what's interesting
about this is that it's going to be
available to people who buy the retail
version of our game that we have coming
out first okay just a sort of in a way
to say thank you and welcome to the
community but then we will have it
available worldwide digitally for sale a
few weeks later so everyone can grab it
it's a what's the price options for
these is this standard from 99 doggone
I'm per car and it will come with six
different skins that you can use and
then they'll also have their own unique
set of wheels that you can use and you
can of course use those on any car that
you want the mapfre always free arm
athlete always be free apps forever and
how do you guys feel about your current
pricing model and how how's the
community been reacting to it seems like
you guys have been adding so much
content consistently to try to keep
people coming back for more but then
you're also offering options for people
to personalize their cars a little bit
so it's got like a TS vibe to it right
where you're like able to yeah customize
yourself deck it out but it doesn't
impact gameplay no and that's best the
key is we anything that we charge for we
didn't want it to be something that made
you feel like if you didn't buy it that
you couldn't compete with anyone it's
really more about just feeling like you
can express yourself from the ways that
you want to and that's our whole
philosophy that will always be our
philosophy and we think the community
likes it quite a bit because they've we
have really good numbers in terms of
people who are downloading it using the
cars and the things that really matter
to the community as a whole the maps the
modes we don't charge for those we want
everyone to play them and that's that's
always going to be our strategy going
forward and so far it's worked out
pretty well yeah absolutely I think
about expressing myself in do Tokyo I'm
mi
I akira tattoo are there any of the cars
that embody sort of the facets of nato's
bike well we definitely yes we have
there's another car that we have in here
called Esper when this game is over Luke
can switch to it oh yeah and it's it's
definitely reminiscent of of something
out of the Kiera for sure okay cool um
within within the rules of parody all
right of course yeah yes you guys have
multiple cars you have these two but
you're also of already announced two
more cars yeah Marauder and aftershock
yes you guys are constantly pumping out
new things here yeah those are callbacks
to our old supersonic acrobatic
rocket-powered battle cars they were two
of the the tight of the vehicles that
didn't make it in the initial release
that were from that game and so we
brought them over and aftershock in
particular was one that a lot of our
fans including some of our top players
like Renault views one of the best
players in the world oh we know oh yeah
talk to notice we're trying to get him
on speed dial for when we had the game
spot competition against you being uh
he's in the building it's my girl will
track him down actually speaking of the
the game spot I think Josh had something
you wanted to mention about compensating
the last time we saw you you were
supposed to bring our challenge back to
the team that's right we've been ready
and waiting for rematch I think we have
the new battleground now rice get the
squad together do it let's do it
actually I'm I showed them yeah when I
visited psionics for the reveal of your
guys's rocket labs I got video of you
guys calling out the team and I showed
it to the team who is here by the way
and I think rabbit meat even take I
think you can hear yeah we heard it Rob
handlery somewhere upset we were
thinking about even doing it here at e3
but it sounds like the actual people we
competed against aren't all here oh yeah
oh you want like a true imagine
everybody you guys didn't have the
people available oh oh okays like
somebody got scared right
I don't know I'm sure they're watching
now you guys should look at your books
and make sure that your best players can
make it to hurry for these types of
moment well we'll make a few phone calls
/ worse it will see what happens there
right yeah they're right down in San
Diego yeah we can quick trained by bus
yeah we are super down for another
rematch these boys have been working
hard and I think they're ready for
another match I'll the coaching's been
strong so everybody this is this is the
the extra car we mention though I think
that that has the key revive you look
it's left yeah there are a few elements
of it that I can tell are definitely
like inspired yeah it's not one to one
but it's not too far off yeah we wanted
that we wanted the feeling of neo tokyo
we didn't wanted to say this is totally
something you've seen before we wanted
to give it that rocket League vibe and
death one thing while we were talking
that you may or may not have seen as the
new postgame celebrations we had that
are also going into this patch yeah
where you can jump and you can spin you
can use your rock and we also assign
titles relevant to your performance in
the match so if you had the most goals
or the most first touches you play
overwatch I was thinking how great it
would be to have a play of the game or
something in rockaway is that something
you guys might be considering down the
road where you can sort of highlight
those really insane moment maybe like
I'm sick save because those are almost
never really I like being able to be
seeing later on replays but I but at the
end of the match to really just remind
everyone like MVP so there aren't any
guarantees but it's definitely not yet
anyway but it's definitely among the
things we've talked about it something
new and a lot of our updates going
forward starting with neo tokyo are
really about quality of life updates
things that community really wants to
see things that they've been wanting us
to add so things along those lines are
definitely the sorts of things that
we're looking at yeah and you guys are
constantly making updates it's so cool
to see the background of this map I'm
like not distracted the point where I
wouldn't be able to play the game but as
a viewer who's not currently
playing it's so awesome to see all the
bright lights and the colors in the
background you guys did such a great job
is kind of capturing that five of Tokyo
and it looks really good artists work
really really hard on it they spent I
think they probably spent more time on
this method any of the other ones yeah
I'm pretty sure about that they this was
a labor of love for them it's one that
we've been wanting to do for a really
long time when you visited our office to
to see rocket labs for the first time
yeah they had already started working on
way back then so it's something that
they've been waiting for a long time to
get everyone the in front of everyone
we're glad that we finally get to do
that anything else Peter I'm gonna watch
I know I'm was really a big way to Tony
you know rocket League was in our
discussions for game of the year and
last year and we ended up giving it
second place in the overall ranking
that's right and and it's the sort of
game that until you play it it's so hard
to really describe just how fascinating
the process of interacting with the ball
is and with other cars and just the
chaos that's there but how you can learn
how to control that chaos yes I think
this is game that everyone should play
and as someone who really only picked it
up in the last maybe six months I
realized I think I've been missing this
like this is what I need out of a game
something that I just you know I play it
on like one more match just just one
more match good and it like two hours
later I'm like okay just look if it well
there goes my birthday the same sob
story for everyone here yeah well that
that's what we want though is we want
people to have fun even if they're
losing because we do know that there it
is a game that does involve skill at the
highest levels where people can really
pull off some crazy stuff that we didn't
even know was possible until they
started doing it sure but our goal from
the very beginning has always been just
to try to make the game as intuitive and
as fun as possible so it didn't matter
if you were a pro level player or just
starting that you can just drop in and
play and understand it how's the the
reception been for the the basketball
mode huge huge yeah yeah its people love
that mode much more than we thought we
were a little concern in the beginning
because it is a little bit of an
advanced mode given the entire
yeah there's a lot in the intro you
actually have to Ariel in order to start
that [ __ ] like that that mode which is
really crazy it was so funny because the
AI didn't know to do that so if you did
it all the AI just smashed into each
other when we started yeah but uh it
worked out really well for for everyone
we people embraced it and they realize
there's a slightly different skill set
you need Emily and so I I I think that
it's like a lot of the other things
we've done it's gone way beyond what we
originally hoped so we're just happy we
can keep bringing people and we're
working on more modes by the way oh I'm
sure you are talking about them yet but
they're coming soon a bag of secrets and
Jeff somewhere and also anyone who has
seen the trailer was probably enamored
with the amazing music you guys do such
a great job with your music I know a lot
of it is done in-house which is even
more amazing cast another he's wrapped
over the hoops trailer that's oh that's
just incredible you guys do that and it
sounds like for people who do enjoy
rocket League music you guys have
something else that you're going to be
showing for everyone else do we release
the official soundtrack last year that's
alone along with the release of the game
but now we're putting together a volume
two it's going to be coming out very
very soon and within the next few weeks
and it's going to incorporate all the
music that we've released in the game
post our initial launch and then some of
the things that we haven't shown yet so
that's so exciting really cool yeah it's
so good to have those tunes just like
whenever you want them and man they're
so catchy that sometimes you just just
just listen to rock Utley yeah to get
through the day Josh and Jeremy thank
you so much when can people expect to
see a neo tokyo and then the next two
cars afterwards so new Tokyo the map
will be available to everyone worldwide
on Monday June twentieth for free for
free no charge along with all the other
features are getting which is the
postgame celebrations quick chat
customizations brand new rocket labs map
all sorts of stuff they're throwing in
there and then the kind anyone who buys
the retail version of rocket League
which comes out june twenty-fourth in
Europe and July fifth North America will
have access to all the new cars that we
showed you everyone else will then be
able to get them for sale digitally July
eighteenth that's a lot of dates to keep
track of but that's all of them pause
get your calendars out write it down
huge
right thank you so much Sharon Thank You
Josh and thank you guys for that live
demo of neo tokyo it looks rad if you
guys aren't playing rocket league yet I
don't know what's wrong with you put it
on the other screen keep gamespot right
here we got a lot still coming up and we
will see you in just a little bit see
you soon you're watching the game spot
stage brought to you by airheads